A note before we get started, this story begins with a reference to the 1955 lynching of 14-year-old Emmett Till. There's also a moment in the episode in which a guest describes being called the N-word. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Every two years, the Whitney Museum in New York hosts a special exhibit featuring contemporary American art. The show is a big deal. It draws crowds from around the world and can turn artists into stars. But in 2017, one painting in a fifth floor gallery prompted a barrage of criticism over race and appropriation.
在开始之前，先做一个说明：这个故事以1955年14岁少年埃米特·蒂尔（Emmett Till）遭私刑杀害的事件为开头。本期节目中还有一段内容，嘉宾描述了自己被称呼为“黑鬼”（N-word）的经历。这里是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain），我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedanta）。每两年，纽约惠特尼美术馆（Whitney Museum）都会举办一场当代美国艺术特展。这个展览非常重要，它吸引了来自世界各地的观众，并能让艺术家一举成名。但在2017年，五楼展厅里的一幅画作引发了关于种族和挪用的激烈批评。
The painting was called Open Casket. Its artist Dana Schutzt's interpretation of a famous photograph of Emmett Till. He was the young black boy brutally beaten and killed by two white men in Mississippi in 1955. His mother, Mami Till, insisted on an open casket funeral, so the world could see what these men had done to her little boy. Decades later, she described the moment in a documentary, the untold story of Emmett Lewis Till. I said I want the world to see this, because there's no way I can tell this story and give them the visual picture of what my son looked like. The photograph of Emmett Till in the open casket
这幅画名为《敞开的棺材》（Open Casket）。艺术家达娜·舒茨（Dana Schutz）解读了埃米特·蒂尔那张著名的照片。他是一位年轻的黑人男孩，1955年在密西西比州被两名白人男子残忍殴打并杀害。他的母亲玛米·蒂尔（Mamie Till）坚持举行敞开棺材的葬礼，好让全世界看到这些人对她的小儿子做了什么。几十年后，她在纪录片《埃米特·路易斯·蒂尔未被讲述的故事》（The Untold Story of Emmett Louis Till）中描述了那一刻。她说：“我希望全世界都能看到，因为我无法用语言描述我儿子的样子，只能通过视觉画面呈现。”埃米特·蒂尔躺在敞开棺材里的那张照片
remains a painful but powerful touchstone for many, a reminder of the suffering produced by racial injustice. Dana Schutz, who is white, interpreted the photo in a way that was more abstract, but also disturbing. Emmett tells Sout is crisp and pristine. The brutality inflicted on his face is represented with slashing strokes of browns and reds. Shortly after Schutz's painting appeared at the Whitney, dozens of artists of colour demanded that it be removed and destroyed. Before the graph of Emmett Till, they felt, was not open to interpretation by a white artist. It was not okay, they said, to use black paint as raw material for white creativity. African-American author and radio producer Rebecca Carroll said she understood why people
对许多人来说，它仍然是一个痛苦但强有力的试金石，提醒着人们种族不公所带来的苦难。身为白人的达娜·舒茨以一种更抽象、但也更令人不安的方式解读了这张照片。埃米特·蒂尔的脸部轮廓清晰而原始，脸上遭受的暴行用棕色和红色的粗犷笔触表现出来。舒茨的画作在惠特尼美术馆展出后不久，数十位有色人种艺术家要求将其撤下并销毁。他们认为，埃米特·蒂尔的照片不应由白人艺术家来解读。他们说，将黑人的痛苦作为白人创作的原材料是不可接受的。非裔美国作家兼广播制作人丽贝卡·卡罗尔（Rebecca Carroll）表示，她理解为什么人们
were so upset. Schutz's work, she said, is not what Mimi Till would have wanted. When she said, I want them to see this image, she meant Dana Schutz. You know what I'm saying? She meant that it was white America that put her boy in a casket. She didn't mean I want you to see this image and then interpret it the way that you fancy. But there were also voices of color defending the painting. Here's Woopy Goldberg and ABC News legal correspondent Sunny Haashton on the view. People calling for the destruction of
会如此愤怒。她说，舒茨的作品并不是玛米·蒂尔所希望的。当她说“我希望他们看到这张照片”时，她指的并不是达娜·舒茨。你明白我的意思吗？她的意思是，是白人美国把她的儿子放进了棺材里。她并不是说“我希望你们看到这张照片，然后随心所欲地去解读它”。但也有一些有色人种的声音在为这幅画辩护。以下是乌比·戈德堡（Whoopi Goldberg）和美国广播公司新闻法律记者桑尼·霍斯汀（Sunny Hostin）在《观点》（The View）节目中的对话。人们呼吁销毁
art goes very, very hard for me because I did Nazis that. The Nazis want God to get rid of stuff that we don't like. Burn the book. Do this. It's also offensive that she says it's cultural appropriation. It seems like they don't really understand what cultural appropriation is. This is not cultural appropriation. This is, I think, trying to make sure that Emmett Till's mother's pain is America's pain. This week on Hidden Brain, we explore a question at the heart of this controversy. It's a question that touches on the injustices of the past
艺术作品让我感到非常、非常难以接受，因为我看到了纳粹的影子。纳粹想要除掉我们不喜欢的东西。烧书，做各种事。她说这是文化挪用，这也很冒犯人。看起来他们并不真正理解什么是文化挪用。这不是文化挪用。我认为，这是在试图确保埃米特·蒂尔母亲的痛苦成为美国的痛苦。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨这场争议核心的一个问题。这是一个触及过去不公正现象的问题，
and the increasingly caustic tone of modern cultural debates. It's a question that affects the art world, but also extends far beyond it, reaching into fiction and journalism. When is it okay to tell a story that is not your own? Is doing so an act of empathy or an act of disrespect? Even theft. Not long ago, writer Gail Shepard got her first novel published. The true history of Lindy B. Hawkins is for middle-grade kids. It tells a story of an 11-year-old girl Lindy and her troubled family.
以及现代文化辩论中日益尖锐的基调。这是一个影响艺术界，但也远超艺术界，延伸到小说和新闻领域的问题。什么时候可以讲述一个不属于你的故事？这样做是同理心的表现，还是不尊重的行为？甚至是盗窃？不久前，作家盖尔·谢泼德（Gail Shepard）出版了她的第一部小说。《琳迪·B·霍金斯真实历史》（The True History of Lindy B. Hawkins）是为中学生写的。它讲述了一个11岁女孩琳迪和她陷入困境的家庭的故事。
Lindy's father is an out-of-work Vietnam vet with PTSD. Her mother is withdrawn and barely gets out of bed. The three of them have moved into Lindy's grandparents' house in Tennessee. Monday morning, first day of seventh grade. I'm standing in Lady and grand-pathads hallway, alone, in my stiff spotless blazer and iron pleaded skirt and polished loafers holding my new divider notebooks lady brought me. Ma was still asleep, she got home late from selling girdles last night.
琳迪的父亲是一名患有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的失业越战老兵。她的母亲意志消沉，几乎下不了床。他们三人搬进了琳迪在田纳西州的祖父母家中。周一早上，七年级的第一天。我独自站在琳迪和祖父母的走廊里，穿着挺括、一尘不染的西装外套，熨烫平整的百褶裙和擦得锃亮的乐福鞋，手里拿着琳迪给我买的新活页笔记本。妈妈还在睡觉，她昨晚卖束身衣回来得很晚。
Daddy's awake, I know because I hear his footsteps pacing upstairs in his bedroom, but he didn't answer when I knocked earlier. The novel covers tough issues, hidden secrets, family strife, alcoholism. It has been very well received, but ours is not just a story about this book. It's a story of how this book came to be. You see, Gail's book is based on another person's story. To understand the deep ethical questions we are exploring today, we need to start not with the true history of Lindy B. Hawkins, but the true history of somebody else. That other history is long and complex, and it leads us to the questions we
爸爸醒了，我知道，因为我听到他在楼上卧室里踱步的声音，但我之前敲门时他没有回应。这部小说涵盖了棘手的问题：隐藏的秘密、家庭冲突、酗酒。它受到了很好的评价，但我们的故事不仅仅是关于这本书。它是关于这本书是如何诞生的。你看，盖尔的书是基于另一个人的故事。为了理解我们今天探讨的深刻伦理问题，我们需要从头开始，不是从《琳迪·B·霍金斯真实历史》开始，而是从另一个人的真实历史开始。那段历史漫长而复杂，它引出了我们
are exploring today. Questions about empathy, identity, art and ownership. Chapter 1 The Muse Once upon a time there was a little girl. Her name was Kimela. Her father was a blue-eyed, blonde-haired, military man. My father was a veteran, and he was a veteran in the Korean War. Her mother was Asian. My mother is Filipino.
今天正在探讨的问题。关于同理心、身份、艺术和所有权的问题。第一章：缪斯。很久很久以前，有一个小女孩。她的名字叫基梅拉（Kimela）。她的父亲是一个蓝眼睛、金头发的军人。我父亲是一名退伍军人，他是朝鲜战争的老兵。她的母亲是亚洲人。我母亲是菲律宾人。
Kimela was born in Santa Ana, California in the late 50s. We're not using her last name to protect her family's privacy. Camilla remembers her neighborhood as a kind of melting pot filled with lots of different people, whites, blacks, Asians, Hispanics. She was a mixed-trace kid, and in Santa Ana, she fit right in. When she was 10, her family piled into a car, and headed east. My father wanted to take the family back to the south to Georgia. Almost from the start, Kimmila says. Things fell off. When they crossed the Mississippi River, she looked up, and saw a sky she didn't recognize. Gone was the vast canopy of blue she knew so well.
基梅拉于50年代末出生在加利福尼亚州的圣安娜。为了保护她家人的隐私，我们不使用她的姓氏。基梅拉记得她的社区就像一个大熔炉，住着各种各样的人：白人、黑人、亚洲人、西班牙裔。她是一个混血孩子，在圣安娜，她完全融入其中。她10岁那年，全家挤进一辆车，向东出发。我父亲想带全家回到南方的佐治亚州。基梅拉说，几乎从一开始，事情就变了。当他们穿过密西西比河时，她抬头看去，看到了一片她不认识的天空。她所熟悉的广阔蓝天不见了。
In its place was a low, heavy sky, crowded with clouds. Finally, the family pulled into their new hometown, make in peace. It was a summer of 1968. Smack in the middle of the civil rights movement. Feed your life on your friends. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Soon after they arrived, the new school year began.
取而代之的是一片低沉、厚重、乌云密布的天空。最终，全家搬进了他们的新家乡——佐治亚州的梅肯（Macon）。那是1968年的夏天，正值民权运动的高潮。……（歌词略）……他们到达后不久，新学年就开始了。
Camilla and her older brother went together. Soon after they arrived, the new school year began. Kamella and her older brother went together. We would walk to our new school and then we would walk home at the end of the day. But one morning, her brother was sick and Kamella went alone. She hadn't paid that much attention to the route. She made it to school. But on my way home after school, I got lost. I had taken a wrong turn somewhere along the way and ended up in a different neighborhood,
基梅拉和她哥哥一起去上学。他们到达后不久，新学年就开始了。基梅拉和她哥哥一起去上学。我们走着去新学校，然后在一天结束时走回家。但有一天早上，她哥哥病了，基梅拉独自一人去了。她没太注意路线。她到了学校。但在放学回家的路上，我迷路了。我在路上的某个地方转错了弯，最终到了一个不同的社区，
which I did not recognize. And in that moment of being lost and feeling very alone and vulnerable, I was suddenly surrounded by four white boys, a little bit older than me, who were calling me names, and they called me a nigger, and also they picked up stones and threw stones at me. And I remember being absolutely terrified and running as fast as I could off that block. In this new place, under a different sky, in a time of racial turmoil, Kimela had learned her first lesson.
那是我不认识的地方。就在那一刻，在迷路、感到非常孤独和脆弱的时候，我突然被四个比我大一点的白人男孩包围了，他们辱骂我，叫我“黑鬼”（nigger），还捡起石头扔我。我记得当时非常害怕，拼命跑出了那个街区。在这个新的地方，在不同的天空下，在种族动荡的时期，基梅拉学到了她的第一课。
Skin color mattered. You were either white or you were black. The problem for Kimmila was that she was neither. My skin was in between. It was not black, but it was a color of brownish yellow. But brownish yellow wasn't a category that was allowed. For Kimmila, the conflict raging in the world outside was mirrored by a conflict in her inner world. Kimmila felt she was being asked to choose between her father, who was white, and her mother, from whom she got her darker skin. In the racial hierarchy of Mekin, Georgia, one parent was clearly superior, the other, inferior.
肤色很重要。你要么是白人，要么是黑人。基梅拉的问题在于她两者都不是。我的皮肤介于两者之间。它不是黑色的，而是一种棕黄色。但棕黄色不是一个被允许的类别。对于基梅拉来说，外部世界肆虐的冲突反映在她内心的冲突中。基梅拉觉得她被迫在父亲（白人）和母亲（她从母亲那里继承了较深的肤色）之间做出选择。在佐治亚州梅肯的种族等级制度中，一方显然是优越的，另一方是低劣的。
Whom would she identify with? Ten-year-old Camilla went with a safer option. She picked the white parent. Because that was the side that had power. That was made very clear to me. Camilla didn't have her father's light skin and blue eyes, but she was lighter skin than her mother and could pass for white. She embraced the safety it brought. She never sought to learn her mother's native language,
她会认同谁呢？10岁的基梅拉选择了更安全的选择。她选择了白人父亲。因为那是拥有权力的一方。这一点对我来说非常清楚。基梅拉没有父亲那样的浅肤色和蓝眼睛，但她比母亲肤色浅，可以冒充白人。她拥抱了这种安全感。她从没想过要学习母亲的母语，
Tagalog. For Camilla to do this, to claim only her white half, men giving up something she cherished, the part of her that came from her mother, with whom she felt a deep emotional connection. It's a very painful kind of betrayal to turn on your own mother or turn on your own people. She remembers moments when this betrayal exploded into the open. It happened once when she was 15. Her mother had just driven her to school and they had a conflict about something. And I remember standing outside the car and I screamed at her in the parking lot of the junior high school in front of all these people. I remember I screamed at her and I remember as soon as
他加禄语。对于基梅拉来说，这样做，只认同她白人的一半，意味着放弃她所珍视的东西——她身上来自母亲的那一部分，她与母亲有着深厚的情感联系。背叛自己的母亲或背叛自己的人民是一种非常痛苦的背叛。她记得这种背叛爆发出来的时刻。那是在她15岁时发生的一次。她母亲刚开车送她去学校，他们因为某事发生了冲突。我记得我站在车外，在初中停车场当着所有人的面冲她尖叫。我记得我冲她尖叫，我记得一旦
she was gone, I felt so horrible inside. I felt so bad about that. It wasn't just what she said. I don't really remember the words, but it was more an attitude of talking down to her in the way that I had seen my father talk down to her. It was disrespectful. Camilla realized that she was treating her mother the same way her father treated her mother.
她离开后，我内心感到非常糟糕。我对此感到非常难过。不仅仅是因为她说了什么。我不记得具体的话了，但更多的是一种居高临下的态度，就像我看到我父亲对她说话那样。那是不尊重的。基梅拉意识到，她对待母亲的方式和她父亲对待母亲的方式一模一样。
I was identifying with my father and taking that father voice that had diminished my mother who was on the Filipino side of the family. Camila still vividly remembers a family car trip. My brother and I in the back seat and my father was driving and my mother in the passenger seat. And there was some tension. It was another bad day. He was in a bad mood. He was driving too fast.
我认同了我的父亲，并采用了那种父亲的声音，贬低了我的母亲，也就是家庭中菲律宾裔的那一方。基梅拉至今仍清晰地记得一次家庭自驾游。我和哥哥坐在后座，父亲在开车，母亲坐在副驾驶座。气氛有些紧张。那是又一个糟糕的日子。他心情不好。他开得太快了。
And my mother asked him to slow down. And he did the opposite. He hit the accelerator and he drove faster and faster until she broke down and started to cry. Finally, he pulled over. My brother and I were petrified in the back seat and my mother got out of the car and she was shaking like a trummers. And she was shaking all through her body on the side of the road. In time, Camilla came to realize that the ghosts of her father's war experiences were behind his volatility. Much as she sought to be her father's daughter,
我母亲让他慢点。但他却反其道而行之。他猛踩油门，越开越快，直到她崩溃大哭。最后，他把车停在路边。我和哥哥在后座吓坏了，我母亲下了车，她像筛糠一样颤抖。她在路边全身都在颤抖。随着时间的推移，基梅拉开始意识到，她父亲战争经历的阴影是他情绪不稳定的原因。尽管她努力想成为父亲的女儿，
she remembers deep trauma in their relationship. Kimela's father was an avid hunter. He gave her a rifle and taught her to shoot. And the day came when my father asked me if I wanted to go with my brother and him to your hunting and I said yes. They went out together father son and daughter and on that day very first time a buck came into my range where I was stationed in a tree. Kimila didn't want to shoot, but she felt she had to. And I did what I had been taught, and I shot that deer dead.
但她记得他们关系中深层的创伤。基梅拉的父亲是一位狂热的猎人。他给了她一支步枪，教她射击。有一天，父亲问我是否想和哥哥以及他一起去打猎，我说好。他们一起出发了，父亲、儿子和女儿。那天，我第一次看到一只雄鹿进入了我在树上的射击范围。基梅拉不想开枪，但她觉得她必须这么做。我照着我被教导的那样做了，我把那只鹿射死了。
But as she watched the deer fall to the ground, she realized she was not her father's daughter after all. We'll never forget that day until the day I die because immediately after I was full of regret. What had she done she wondered? Why had she taken a life? The moment scarred her. It didn't occur to Camilla that this complicated life story could be the plot of a book.
但当她看着鹿倒在地上时，她意识到自己终究不是父亲的女儿。直到我死的那一天，我都不会忘记那一天，因为在那之后，我充满了悔恨。她想，她做了什么？为什么要夺走一个生命？那一刻在她心中留下了伤痕。基梅拉当时并没有想到，这段复杂的人生故事可以成为一本书的情节。
It was just a difficult part of her childhood that she kept bottled up. CHAPTER 2 Chapter 2. Friendship. In the mid-1980s, Kimmel Estara graduated school at the University of Florida. One night she attended a poetry recital and listened as a fellow student read some of her work. She felt a connection. I was very drawn to her aesthetic sensibility and to the way that she saw the world. The classmate's name was Gail Sheppard.
这只是她童年时期一段被她封存起来的痛苦经历。第二章：友谊。80年代中期，基梅拉在佛罗里达大学读研究生。一天晚上，她参加了一场诗歌朗诵会，听一位同学朗读她的作品。她感到了一种共鸣。我非常被她的审美感和她看待世界的方式所吸引。那位同学的名字叫盖尔·谢泼德（Gail Sheppard）。
Camila was captivated by Gail's writing. She was captivated by Gail. I remember I would try and say hi to her when we passed each other walking across campus. And for months and months, I would try and wave and say hi, and she would just walk right by me as if she hadn't seen me.
基梅拉被盖尔的文字迷住了。她被盖尔迷住了。我记得当我们在校园里擦肩而过时，我会试着跟她打招呼。几个月来，我一直试着挥手说嗨，但她就像没看见我一样直接走过去。
And I thought, Maya, she's not interested in being friends. Later, I found out that she's legally blind in one eye and refused to wear glasses. And she never saw me. Gail, in fact, had noticed Camilla. Her first memory of her is more like a flashback, just an image of a young woman on campus with an injured shoulder. I think she had fallen or gotten hurt somehow.
我想，也许她不想交朋友。后来我发现，她的一只眼睛在法律上是盲的，而且拒绝戴眼镜。她根本没看见我。事实上，盖尔注意到了基梅拉。她对基梅拉的第一印象更像是一个闪回，只是校园里一个肩膀受伤的年轻女子的形象。我想她当时摔倒了或者受了伤。
And she was wearing all white and she was leaning on a cane and her hair was cut really short and she was just the most beautiful creature I'd ever laid eyes on. Eventually, Galen Kimmela became close friends. They spent hours together discussing poetry, film, feminism. They studied shoulder to shoulder for exams. Sometimes late at night, they drove on a whim to the beach. When Gail finished her degree, she moved to London for a job. She and Camila kept in touch through a now forgotten art, letter writing.
她穿着一身白衣，拄着拐杖，头发剪得很短，她是我见过最美丽的生物。最终，盖尔和基梅拉成了好朋友。她们花了很多时间讨论诗歌、电影、女权主义。她们肩并肩为考试复习。有时在深夜，她们会一时兴起开车去海边。盖尔毕业后，搬到伦敦工作。她和基梅拉通过一种现在已被遗忘的艺术——写信，保持着联系。
I remember the feel of the paper that thin blue airmail paper that we used to have? I don't know who sent the first letter, but there was this unspoken agreement that if you sent a letter, you would get a reply. They wrote not just his friends, but his writers. April 25. I imagine the scenario you blew in the light of your computer pounding out your story and Thousands of miles away me saffron in the circle of my reading lamp reading your story You looking postage me looking postage our envelopes blowing kisses at each other as they pass two ships and then like a seven somewhere mid Atlantic
我记得那种纸的触感，那种我们过去用的薄薄的蓝色航空信纸？我不记得是谁寄了第一封信，但有一种默契：如果你寄了一封信，你就会收到回信。她们不仅作为朋友，也作为作家进行交流。4月25日。我想象着这个场景：你在电脑的微光下敲打着你的故事，而几千英里之外，我在阅读灯的圆圈里读着你的故事。你寄出邮资，我寄出邮资，我们的信封在交错时互相亲吻，就像两艘船，然后像大西洋中部的某个地方……
from the cellboat I think of you how you fit into the scheme of my life What you have to do with my identity with who I am with who I want to be One day on that thin airmail paper Kimela wrote about her complicated relationship with her father and her mother. Once there was a man who was a hunter of some renown, a man of the woods, he was a soldier in his youth.
从帆船上，我想起你，想起你如何融入我生命的蓝图。你与我的身份、我是谁、我想成为谁有什么关系。有一天，在那张薄薄的航空信纸上，基梅拉写下了她与父亲和母亲之间复杂的关系。曾经有一个人，他是一位颇有名气的猎人，一个森林之子，他年轻时是一名士兵。
An American a Scottish descent, he married a Filipino woman and had a family. She told Gail about the time her father took her hunting. When the lesson was over, the girl knew everything there was to know about the smell of fear and death. She smelled the odor of blood and feces and urine, and she remembered all the times he had made her smell it. She didn't want to kill anything ever again. 23rd May. That terrible bloody letter you sent me. It scared me. You didn't have to tell me
一个苏格兰裔美国人，他娶了一位菲律宾女性，组建了一个家庭。她告诉盖尔，她父亲带她去打猎的那次经历。当课程结束时，那个女孩对恐惧和死亡的气味了如指掌。她闻到了血、粪便和尿液的味道，她记得他让她闻到这些味道的所有时刻。她再也不想杀任何东西了。5月23日。你寄给我的那封可怕的血腥信件。它吓坏我了。你没必要告诉我
that. You didn't have to disembowel yourself yet again. But such honesty brought them even closer. Gail identified deeply with Camela. There are so many words I want to write to you and for you. They crowd together. I'm hoping that someday I can make something beautiful for you, a picture, a story, a real of film, which will show you what you've done without my having to say it. By the time Gail returned to the United States, she and Camilla were deeply in love.
那些。你没必要再次剖开自己。但这种诚实让她们更加亲近。盖尔深深地认同基梅拉。有太多的话我想写给你，为你而写。它们挤在一起。我希望有一天我能为你创造一些美丽的东西，一张照片，一个故事，一段电影，它会向你展示你所做的一切，而无需我开口。当盖尔回到美国时，她和基梅拉深深地相爱了。
They moved together to Pittsburgh where Camilla taught and Gail wrote. For seven years, they were a couple. In the end, the relationship didn't survive. The eventual breakup was painful and complex as the breakups tend to be. Both women moved on. Camilla found her way back to California and the vast blue sky of her early childhood. Gail returned to Florida. Their letters were packed carefully into boxes
她们一起搬到了匹兹堡，基梅拉在那里教书，盖尔在那里写作。七年来，她们是一对伴侣。最终，这段关系没能维持下去。分手是痛苦而复杂的，就像所有的分手一样。两个人都继续前行。基梅拉回到了加利福尼亚，回到了她童年时期那片广阔的蓝天。盖尔回到了佛罗里达。她们的信件被小心地装进盒子里，
and put away. Chapter 3. The Book Close to 20 years after Gail and Kimela went their own ways, an idea for a novel began to take shape in Gail's imagination. She turned it over in her mind, thinking about narrative, voice, plot. When she was in her 50s, Gail invented a character, Lindy. She outlined the story in her mind. The upshot of the story was it's a 12-year-old Vietnamese American daughter of a white war veteran and a Vietnamese woman. And she's growing up in the deep south and she's basically coping with, you know, the legacy of Southern racism and violence from her father's work experience. He has PTSD.
收了起来。第三章：书。在盖尔和基梅拉分道扬镳近20年后，盖尔的脑海中开始构思一部小说的想法。她在脑海中反复思考，构思叙事、声音、情节。当她50多岁时，盖尔创造了一个角色——琳迪。她在脑海中勾勒出这个故事。故事的梗概是：一个12岁的越南裔美国女孩，父亲是白人越战老兵，母亲是越南人。她在南方腹地长大，基本上是在应对父亲战争经历带来的南方种族主义和暴力的遗产。他患有PTSD。
You know by now that the inspiration for this book was Kimela. In real life, Kimela's mother was from the Philippines and her father was a Korean war veteran. But Gail knew more about the Vietnam War, so she made Lindy's mother Vietnamese, and her father, a Vietnam war vet. Gail diverged from Kimela's story in other ways. For example, she gave Lindy a close friend. Growing up, Camilla had also had a close friend and African-American girl. Gail made the friend a boy, DB. And DB in the first draft of the novel was Native American. As Gail was thinking through the story, she found herself headed to California. The trip
你现在知道这本书的灵感来源是基梅拉。在现实生活中，基梅拉的母亲来自菲律宾，父亲是朝鲜战争老兵。但盖尔对越南战争了解更多，所以她把琳迪的母亲设定为越南人，父亲设定为越战老兵。盖尔在其他方面也偏离了基梅拉的故事。例如，她给了琳迪一个好朋友。成长过程中，基梅拉也有一个好朋友，一个非裔美国女孩。盖尔把这个朋友设定为一个男孩，DB。在小说的初稿中，DB是美洲原住民。当盖尔思考这个故事时，她发现自己要前往加利福尼亚。这次旅行
gave her a chance to catch up with her old friend. Kimela remembers the visit vividly. I saw her in California coming in to do a writer's workshop up in Big Sur. So we drove up together and that's when I really became aware that she was seriously writing a novel that had anything to do with my story. I asked Kimela how she felt about gay turning her life story into a book. I felt honored. I felt blessed by that because I had a sense that
给了她一个机会去见她的老朋友。基梅拉对那次访问记忆犹新。我在加利福尼亚见到她，她来大苏尔（Big Sur）参加一个作家工作坊。所以我们一起开车去，那时我才真正意识到她正在认真写一部与我的故事有关的小说。我问基梅拉，对于盖尔把她的人生故事写成书，她有什么感觉。我感到很荣幸。我感到很幸运，因为我有一种感觉，
it was going to provide another opportunity for me to self-reflect about my own story because this was going to be through her eyes. It was going to go through whatever creative process writers go through to create stories that have meaning for a broad audience, but it was for me personally going to give me another chance to do some healing work. I remember very well sitting at her kitchen table in Santa Monica and talking about it. And I never felt anything with Camilla except that she was completely supportive of any creative work that I wanted to do.
它将为我提供另一个机会，让我通过她的视角来反思我自己的故事。它将经历作家为了创作出对广大受众有意义的故事所必须经历的任何创作过程，但对我个人而言，它将给我另一个进行疗愈的机会。我清楚地记得坐在她圣莫尼卡的餐桌旁谈论这件事。除了完全支持我想要做的任何创作工作之外，我对盖尔没有任何其他感觉。
So I mean, she loved it. You know, we had a really great deep conversation about it and just talked, you know, for hours about it at that time and that she was just super supportive about it. I remember there was talking in the car, you know, trying to sort of map out some of the talking in the car, trying to sort of map out some of the personal stuff that I remembered about my own story, but this was so much beyond my story, right? And so the conversation was also about, like archetypal, what the heck was this story really about? And what parts of the story were important
所以，她是真的很喜欢。你知道，我们当时进行了非常深入的对话，谈了几个小时，她对此非常支持。我记得我们在车里谈话，试图梳理出我记得的关于我个人故事的一些东西，但这已经远远超出了我的故事，对吧？所以谈话也涉及到了原型，这个故事到底在讲什么？哪些部分对今天的人们来说很重要，
for people to hear today, because there was some kind of universal aspect to that. Over the next two years, Gail wrote ferociously, when she was done, she'd completed the manuscript for the true history of Lindy B. Huckins. In 2014, she sent the manuscript to her agent who shopped it around, and editor at a prominent publishing house quickly snatched it up. The publication date was set for 2016. But this happened to be a moment of soul searching for the publishing world.
因为这其中有一种普遍性。在接下来的两年里，盖尔疯狂地写作。完成后，她完成了《琳迪·B·霍金斯真实历史》的手稿。2014年，她把手稿寄给了她的经纪人，经纪人四处推销，一家知名出版社的编辑很快就买下了它。出版日期定在2016年。但这恰好是出版界进行自我反省的时刻。
Critics were charging that for too long white people had had of soul searching for the publishing world. Critics were charging that for too long white people had had a stranglehold over the industry. The writers were white, the editors were white, so were the publishers. It wasn't just the industry that was a problem, but the narratives themselves, the way they were framed. Nigerian novelist Jimimanda Angozi Adice spoke about this in a TED talk. The Palestinian poet, Mourid Buguti, writes that if you want to dispossess a people,
评论家们指责白人长期以来一直把持着这个行业。作家是白人，编辑是白人，出版商也是白人。问题不仅在于行业，还在于叙事本身，以及它们被构建的方式。尼日利亚小说家奇马曼达·恩戈齐·阿迪奇（Chimamanda Ngozi Adichie）在TED演讲中谈到了这一点。巴勒斯坦诗人穆里德·巴尔古提（Mourid Barghouti）写道，如果你想剥夺一个民族，
the simplest way to do it is to tell their story and to start with, secondly, start the story with the arrows of the Native Americans and not with the arrival of the British, and you have an entirely different story. Start the story with the failure of the African States and not with the colonial creation of the African State, and you have an entirely different story. In complete or poorly framed narratives are only part of the problem.
最简单的方法就是讲述他们的故事，并从“第二”开始。从美洲原住民的箭开始讲述故事，而不是从英国人的到来开始，你就会得到一个完全不同的故事。从非洲国家的失败开始讲述故事，而不是从殖民者创造非洲国家开始，你就会得到一个完全不同的故事。不完整或构建不当的叙事只是问题的一部分。
There are also concerns about characters based on grotesque stereotypes. You can see how this works and not just in novels, but in other forms of storytelling. In breakfast at Tiffany's, the 1961 movie based on a Truman Capote novella, the actor Mickey Rooney, who is white, plays a character based on racist stereotypes about Asian people. He's clumsy, with buck teeth, and coke-bottle glasses. His name is Mr. Yunioshie, and he's a Japanese man who lives upstairs from Audrey Hepburn's Harry Hebron's Holly Go Lightly. Oh darling, I am sorry, but I lost my key. What that was two weeks ago? You cannot go on or keep bringing my bill. You're disturbing me.
还有关于基于怪诞刻板印象的角色的担忧。你可以看到它是如何运作的，不仅在小说中，而且在其他形式的叙事中。在1961年根据杜鲁门·卡波特（Truman Capote）中篇小说改编的电影《蒂凡尼的早餐》（Breakfast at Tiffany's）中，白人演员米基·鲁尼（Mickey Rooney）扮演了一个基于对亚洲人种族刻板印象的角色。他笨手笨脚，长着龅牙，戴着可乐瓶底厚的眼镜。他的名字叫尤尼奥希先生（Mr. Yunioshi），是一个住在奥黛丽·赫本（Audrey Hepburn）饰演的霍莉·戈莱特利（Holly Golightly）楼上的日本人。哦，亲爱的，我很抱歉，但我丢了钥匙。那不是两周前的事吗？你不能一直这样，别再送账单来了。你打扰到我了。
You must have a key, me. But I want to do any good. I just lose them all. Stories like this shaped the way Asians were seen not just in the movies, but in real life. Bumbling, awkward, short-sighted. What had gone with the wind? Bumbling, awkward, short-sighted. What a gun with the wind. In the white fantasy land of the story, black slaves served their masters with pleasure,
你一定有钥匙，我……但我什么也做不了。我只是把它们全丢了。这样的故事塑造了亚洲人在电影中乃至现实生活中的形象。笨拙、尴尬、目光短浅。《乱世佳人》（Gone with the Wind）呢？在故事的白人幻想世界里，黑奴们乐于为主人服务，
and often had fun. Quick and time! Who says it's quick and time? I'll say it's quick and time. I'll say it's the foreman. I'll say it's one of the quick and time of terror. Quick and time! Quick and time! If you didn't have access to the storyteller's pen, someone else got to write the story of your life.
而且经常玩得很开心。快点！谁说快点？我说快点。我说这是工头。我说这是恐怖的快点。快点！快点！如果你无法接触到讲故事的人的笔，别人就会写下你的人生故事。
It didn't just define how you were seen. It defined how you saw yourself. As Gale began the process of editing her manuscript for publication, she began to feel uneasy. Had she, a white woman, stepped over a line by making her central character an Asian-American girl. I felt very nervous and insecure about what I was doing. There was a lot of discussion in the blogosphere, on Twitter, a lot of conversations. Some of it got really heated. And I just started to feel more and more like
这不仅定义了别人如何看待你，也定义了你如何看待自己。当盖尔开始为出版编辑手稿时，她开始感到不安。她，一个白人女性，通过将主角设定为一个亚裔美国女孩，是否越界了？我对自己在做的事情感到非常紧张和不安。博客圈、推特上有很多讨论，很多对话。有些讨论变得非常激烈。我开始越来越觉得
I wasn't comfortable writing an Asian American character. It's not my background. And I probably couldn't write it as well as an Asian American author could. Gail called her editor. And I said, Kathy, you know, like I'm committed to this, but I have to tell you, I am not very comfortable, entirely comfortable with writing an Asian American character anymore. It wasn't that Gail didn't feel confident in her deep knowledge of Kimmelah's story.
我不适合写一个亚裔美国角色。这不是我的背景。而且我可能写得不如亚裔美国作家好。盖尔给她的编辑打了电话。我说，凯西，你知道，我致力于此，但我必须告诉你，我不再完全舒服地写一个亚裔美国角色了。并不是盖尔对她深入了解基梅拉的故事没有信心。
She did. But she was a new author, and she was worried about the reception for her first book. I think I was afraid that, you know, book bloggers and reviewers and social media personalities would write me over the coals. And they would write you over the coals to say what? They would say you don't have a right to write about this character because you don't know what it's like to grow up as an Asian-American girl in this culture.
她有信心。但她是一位新作者，她担心第一本书的接受度。我想我害怕书评人、评论家和社交媒体名人会把我批得体无完肤。他们会把你批得体无完肤，说些什么？他们会说你没有权利写这个角色，因为你不知道在这个文化中作为一个亚裔美国女孩长大是什么感觉。
And you must have had sort of an internal conversation in your head where you said, but I have a friend and she's told me this story and I understand the story and I'm writing in some ways based on what she told me, no? Of course, yeah, of course. But Gail imagined shouting wars on Twitter. They might be little room for nuance, for discussion, for her to explain how deeply she knew Kimela's story, how much she empathized with what her friend had been through. And it was more than just fear.
你一定在脑子里进行过某种内部对话，你说，但我有一个朋友，她告诉了我这个故事，我理解这个故事，我在某种程度上是基于她告诉我的内容来写的，不是吗？当然，是的，当然。但盖尔想象着推特上的口水战。那里可能几乎没有细微差别、讨论的空间，也没有让她解释她对基梅拉的故事了解得有多深，她对朋友经历过的事情有多么感同身受。这不仅仅是恐惧。
As Gay listened to the voices of the critics, she found herself agreeing with many of them. As my thinking evolved on it, I felt like these people really have a point. Like there is a way in which I cannot write authentically about being an Asian-American girl in the deep South in the 1980s. Questions about what is authentic and who has the right to tell the stories of women and people of color are still raging across the publishing world.
当盖尔听取评论家的声音时，她发现自己同意他们中的许多人。随着我的想法演变，我觉得这些人确实有道理。确实，我无法真实地写出80年代在南方腹地作为一个亚裔美国女孩的感觉。关于什么是真实的，谁有权讲述女性和有色人种的故事的问题，仍在出版界激烈争论。
A new novel by Jeanine Cummins has opened up a debate about white privilege, racism, and publishing, and the unintended consequences of telling a story that is not your own. It is a novel. It's about a Mexican mother who, she and her son are fleeing to the US border. And one of the points of controversy is that Cummings is actually of Irish and Puerto Rican descent. So, little wonder that a debut author like Gail Shepard would think twice about creating a central character of a different race. Still, when Gail told other writers about her decision, reaction varied widely. Almost uniformly, the white writers were aghast,
珍妮·卡明斯（Jeanine Cummins）的一部新小说引发了关于白人特权、种族主义、出版以及讲述不属于你的故事所带来的意外后果的辩论。这是一部小说。它讲述了一位墨西哥母亲，她和儿子逃往美国边境。争议点之一是卡明斯实际上是爱尔兰裔和波多黎各裔。所以，难怪像盖尔·谢泼德这样的处女作作者会三思而后行，不去创造一个不同种族的主角。尽管如此，当盖尔告诉其他作家她的决定时，反应各不相同。几乎一致地，白人作家感到震惊，
that I would even consider rewriting this book because I was uncomfortable with writing an Asian American character. Most people were floored by that. Now the people of color that I talked to about it were not a guest at all. I mean I have friends who were women of color in my writing groups and we have discussed some of these topics with them and you know, I've asked them how they feel about issues. Like how do you feel when a white writer is writing about a person of color? Are you okay with that?
我竟然会考虑重写这本书，仅仅因为我不舒服写一个亚裔美国角色。大多数人都被惊呆了。而我谈论此事的有色人种朋友们一点也不觉得震惊。我的写作小组里有有色人种女性朋友，我们和她们讨论过一些话题，我问过她们对这些问题的看法。比如，当白人作家写有色人种时，你感觉如何？你对此没问题吗？
And you know, in at least one case, I could remember a writer saying to me that she didn't think there was any way, no matter how much research I did, or how sensitive I was, or how careful I was to create something that was true, that I could possibly represent what it was like to grow up as an African-American. And I had to agree with her. Gail remained torn. As a creative person, she wanted the flexibility to write what she liked. But she also recognized that the debate was not just about her or her book.
你知道，至少有一个例子，我记得一位作家对我说，她认为无论我做多少研究，无论我多么敏感，无论我多么小心地去创造真实的东西，我都不可能表现出作为一个非裔美国人长大的感觉。我不得不同意她的观点。盖尔仍然很纠结。作为一个创作者，她想要灵活地写她喜欢的东西。但她也认识到，这场辩论不仅仅是关于她或她的书。
It was a much larger systemic issue. Gail's editor had a suggestion, a way to make the book more authentic. She said, Why don't we think about writing it from a white perspective? Your Southern, your family is Southern. Why not just make your main character a white Southern girl. Gail found herself teetering between despair and relief. I was like, oh my god, okay, this is going to be a really big hurdle to rewrite this book yet again.
这是一个更大的系统性问题。盖尔的编辑有一个建议，一种让书更真实的方法。她说，为什么不考虑从白人的视角来写呢？你是南方人，你的家庭是南方人。为什么不把你的主角设定为一个白人南方女孩呢？盖尔发现自己徘徊在绝望和解脱之间。我想，天哪，好吧，重写这本书将是一个巨大的障碍。
But she decided to do it. She looked to her own background for inspiration. That grounding for me was the southern half of my family and so I changed the character who was Vietnamese-American to be just a white southern girl growing up in Tennessee. It took her several more years to rewrite the book. The final version of the true history of Lindy B. Hawkins was published in 2019. Gail's first draft of the book had grappled with questions of race and racism, but those disappeared in the final version. Besides changing Lindy's race, Gail also changed the race of her friend, D.B. He was initially
但她决定这样做。她从自己的背景中寻找灵感。对我来说，那种基础是我家庭的南方部分，所以我把那个越南裔美国角色改成了在田纳西州长大的白人南方女孩。她又花了几年时间重写这本书。《琳迪·B·霍金斯真实历史》的最终版本于2019年出版。盖尔的第一稿曾探讨过种族和种族主义问题，但在最终版本中这些内容消失了。除了改变琳迪的种族，盖尔还改变了她朋友DB的种族。他最初
imagined as Native American, but Gail made him white. Gail was happy with the new novel. She felt it was better, more authentic than the original. The book was received well in the publishing world. She felt like she had sidestept what could have been a disaster. But I was left with a question. How did Camilla feel about the new Lindy? I bought the book and read it. And I stretched it out.
被设想为美洲原住民，但盖尔把他改成了白人。盖尔对这本新小说很满意。她觉得它比原版更好、更真实。这本书在出版界受到了好评。她觉得她避开了一场可能发生的灾难。但我留下了一个问题。基梅拉对新琳迪有什么感觉？我买了这本书并读了它。我把它读得很慢。
I read one chapter and then I would put it down. And then a couple days later I would read the second chapter and put it down like that until I got to the end. Camilla was deeply moved. When I read the true story of Lindy B. Hawkins, I still see my story in there. We talked about Gale's decision to change the race of the central character.
我读了一章，然后放下。几天后，我读了第二章，然后放下，就这样一直读到最后。基梅拉深受感动。当我读《琳迪·B·霍金斯真实历史》时，我仍然在里面看到了我的故事。我们谈到了盖尔改变主角种族的决定。
Camilla said she understood it, but also felt that Gale would have been well within her rights to tell the story of an Asian American girl. I thought she had the right to tell it. I mean, I think the hesitation she had was part of the sort of, oh, the fallout of writers in this country and the writers community having to have this difficult conversation about not having enough minority representation in publishing. I kind of feel to some extent, one of the bad fallout of that was that somebody like Gail
基梅拉说她理解，但也觉得盖尔完全有权讲述一个亚裔美国女孩的故事。我认为她有权讲述它。我的意思是，我认为她的犹豫是这个国家作家社区不得不进行这场关于出版界缺乏少数族裔代表性的艰难对话所带来的后果的一部分。我某种程度上觉得，其中一个糟糕的后果是像盖尔这样的人
would decide not to write that story as an Asian American character. What do you think is last when she makes that decision, Kimela? Well, you know, what's lost is the story about the Asian American girl, that we are waiting for some Asian American author to write. And I think that might be the sad piece is, you know, we may be waiting for some time to hear that story. Still.
会决定不写那个亚裔美国角色的故事。基梅拉，你认为当她做出那个决定时，失去了什么？嗯，你知道，失去的是关于那个亚裔美国女孩的故事，我们正在等待某个亚裔美国作家来写。我想这可能是令人悲伤的部分，你知道，我们可能还要等上一段时间才能听到那个故事。仍然。
I mean, is it possible that there's a nine-year-old Asian-American girl somewhere in the country that actually would have liked to have read that book about an Asian-American girl, you know, going through maybe some of the things that she was going through? Without question. Without question. Without question, there would have been. I asked Gail whether anything Kimila had just said made her rethink her decision to change the race of the central character. So you're asking me to speculate how I would have felt if I had talked to Camilla about it before making the changes?
我的意思是，有没有可能全国某个地方有一个9岁的亚裔美国女孩，她其实很想读那本关于亚裔美国女孩的书，你知道，经历着她可能正在经历的一些事情？毫无疑问。毫无疑问。毫无疑问，会有这样的女孩。我问盖尔，基梅拉刚才说的话是否让她重新考虑了改变主角种族的决定。所以你是让我推测如果我在做出改变之前和基梅拉谈过，我会是什么感觉？
Yes. You know, I actually think that there are hundreds of stories that any author can choose to tell. And I have plenty of stories to tell, and there are a lot of authors out there right now, some of them Asian-American, some of them Native-American, some of them African-American. Everybody has stories, and I don't actually see it as a great loss to the children's literature
是的。你知道，我实际上认为任何作者都可以选择讲述数百个故事。我有足够多的故事要讲，现在外面有很多作者，其中一些是亚裔美国人，一些是美洲原住民，一些是非裔美国人。每个人都有故事，我实际上并不认为这是儿童文学的巨大损失，
that this particular story was not told in the original form. Who gets to tell a story? If Camilla's story belongs to her, can she give someone else license to tell it? What if that other person is not Asian? This Camilla's story belongs only to her or do other Asian people have a stake in that story and how it gets told, in who tells it. Chapter 4. The Debate
因为这个特定的故事没有以原始形式讲述。谁有权讲述一个故事？如果基梅拉的故事属于她，她能授权别人讲述吗？如果那个人不是亚洲人呢？这个基梅拉的故事只属于她吗？还是其他亚洲人也对这个故事有利益关系，关于它如何被讲述，以及由谁来讲述。第四章：辩论。
Social psychologists have been studying the relationships between power, identity, and cultural symbols. At a psychology conference in New Orleans, I spoke with Ashley Carter, a postdoctoral fellow at New York University. She says she and her colleagues have looked at why white people adopt the cultural symbols of other groups, from hairstyles to clothing to music. The research suggests that white people who do this are often looking for ways to stand out. What the issue often becomes is if you're a white person in a US context, it's really
社会心理学家一直在研究权力、身份和文化符号之间的关系。在新奥尔良的一次心理学会议上，我采访了纽约大学的博士后研究员阿什利·卡特（Ashley Carter）。她说，她和同事们研究了为什么白人会采用其他群体的文化符号，从发型到服装再到音乐。研究表明，这样做的白人往往是在寻找脱颖而出的方式。问题往往在于，如果你在美国背景下是一个白人，这真的……
hard to feel distinct because you're part of this large amorphous, kind of indistinctive group and so how do you then feel distinct within that group? And so you might look outside of white culture to say, oh, I can maybe take a little bit of this and borrow a little bit of that, and appropriate a little bit of this, so that I'm actually distinct
因为你属于这个庞大、无定形且模糊的群体，所以很难感到自己与众不同。那么，你如何在这个群体中感受到自己的独特性呢？因此，你可能会向白人文化之外寻求灵感，心想，我可以借鉴一点这个，借用一点那个，挪用一点那个，这样我实际上就变得与众不同了。
within this huge cultural group, that's white. Actually says that when white people engage in this sort of borrowing, they report feeling closer to the culture that they're drawing from. But that's often not how their actions are perceived by the people who belong to that other culture. The issue is that minorities often see those same acts as trespassing, and when they do see it as trespassing,
在这个庞大的白人文化群体中。事实上，有人说当白人进行这种借用时，他们会感到与所借鉴的文化更加亲近。但这通常不是该文化群体成员对他们行为的看法。问题在于，少数族裔往往将这些行为视为侵犯，而当他们将其视为侵犯时，
although whites feel more connected to minorities, minorities feel less connected to whites. So is restraint the only solution? Are black people the only ones who should write the stories of black people? Gay people the only ones to create characters that are gay? There's an argument that can be made that this is the only way to truly achieve authenticity and to reduce harmful stereotypes and inaccuracies. But there are other problems that arise with this solution. I'm Kwame Anttiapier and I am Professor of Philosophy and Law at NYU and I also write
尽管白人感到与少数族裔的联系更紧密，但少数族裔却感到与白人的联系减弱了。那么，克制是唯一的解决办法吗？难道只有黑人才能写黑人的故事吗？只有同性恋者才能创作同性恋角色吗？有人认为，这是实现真正真实性并减少有害刻板印象和不准确描述的唯一途径。但这种解决方案也会带来其他问题。我是夸梅·安蒂亚皮尔，我是纽约大学哲学与法学教授，我也撰写
an ethicist column for the York Times Sunday magazine. My discussion with Kwame begins with the question of what it means to be authentic. It turns out that's a complicated question. Take Kwame himself. I was born in London and my mother was English, but my father was from Ghana, which is where the name Kwame and the name apier both come from. Is Kwame an authentic English Apia both come from. Is Kwame an authentic Englishman? An authentic African? When he was young, his family left London and returned to Ghana to a town called Kumasi.
《纽约时报》周日杂志的伦理专栏。我和夸梅的讨论始于“真实意味着什么”这个问题。事实证明，这是一个复杂的问题。以夸梅本人为例。我出生在伦敦，母亲是英国人，但父亲来自加纳，夸梅和安蒂亚皮尔这两个名字都源于那里。夸梅是一个地道的英国人吗？一个地道的非洲人吗？他小时候，家人离开了伦敦，回到了加纳一个叫库马西的城镇。
It's the capital of an old kingdom, so up the hill from us there was a palace with a king in it. Kwame grew up this way. Part African, part English, part white, part black. After this, that Kwame speaks with an upper-class British accent and he's gay. In other words, he's hard to categorize. When he steps into a cab which he does a lot, he says he often gets the same question. The question is where are you from? Where are you from? Sometimes he answers that he was born in London. And that's not what they want to know, because
那是古老王国的首都，所以我们住的山坡上有一座住着国王的宫殿。夸梅就是这样长大的。既是非洲人，又是英国人，既是白人，又是黑人。此后，夸梅说着一口上流社会的英国口音，而且他是同性恋。换句话说，他很难被归类。当他坐进出租车时（他经常坐），他说他经常被问到同样的问题。问题是：你从哪里来？你从哪里来？有时他回答说他出生在伦敦。但那不是他们想知道的，因为
the question that they're interested in is as it were, what I am. Sometimes if the taxi driver in question is sort of brown-skinned as I am, I think they're hoping that my answer will be, I'm a sick like you, or I'm an Egyptian like you or whatever. So in a way, when those people ask it, they're hoping that the answer is, you know, you and I are brothers, is it well. Kwame understands why such conversations happen. So you need some categories that sort of help just ease the flow of human interaction. We do this by grouping people, by race, by country, by gender, by class.
他们感兴趣的问题实际上是：我到底是什么。有时，如果那个出租车司机和我一样是棕色皮肤，我想他们希望我的回答是：“我和你一样是锡克教徒”，或者“我和你一样是埃及人”之类的。所以从某种意义上说，当这些人问这个问题时，他们希望得到的答案是：“你和我是一家人”。夸梅理解为什么会发生这样的对话。你需要一些类别来帮助简化人际互动的流程。我们通过种族、国家、性别和阶级来对人进行分组。
These labels help us make sense of the world and those around us. But there is a problem with these classifications. There are lots of people who are by our scheme of things white or African-American or Asian-American who fit uneasily into the picture because the picture we have is too simple and it leaves out all the vast variation within these categories. Kwame, in other words, might be gay, but he isn't merely gay. He's also African. As a naturalized US citizen, he's also American.
这些标签帮助我们理解世界和周围的人。但这些分类存在一个问题。有很多人，按照我们的分类标准，属于白人、非裔美国人或亚裔美国人，但他们很难融入这个框架，因为我们所拥有的框架太简单了，忽略了这些类别内部巨大的差异。换句话说，夸梅可能是同性恋，但他不仅仅是同性恋。他也是非洲人。作为一名入籍的美国公民，他也是美国人。
He's a New Yorker because that's where he lives. He identifies as English by birth and by accent. And there is another dimension of his life when none of these categories are very meaningful. The most important thing about me when I go to meetings of the American Philosophical Association is that I'm another philosopher, and people aren't super interested in the other dimensions of identity, as long as you can talk the talk that philosophers talk. I ask Kwame what he makes of the curious evolution of the true history of Lindy B. Hawkins and Gail's worries about writing an Asian American character.
他是一名纽约客，因为他住在那里。他认同自己是英国出生，并带有英国口音。他的生活中还有另一个维度，在这些维度中，所有这些类别都没有多大意义。当我参加美国哲学协会会议时，关于我最重要的事情是我是一名哲学家，只要你能用哲学家的方式交谈，人们对身份的其他维度并不太感兴趣。我问夸梅，他如何看待《林迪·B·霍金斯真实历史》的奇特演变，以及盖尔对创作亚裔美国人角色的担忧。
But he's certainly right to be worried that in the Twitter verse there would be people who would excoriate her for cultural appropriation. But I would not be among them. For one thing Kwame says, to think that Gail could not write Kimmila's story is to believe that Kimmila is defined by being Asian, rather than a constellation of different identities, only one of which happens to be her ethnicity. It treats that, Kimmila's experience as if it's itself some kind of generic thing, as if Camilla was
但他担心推特上会有人因文化挪用而抨击她，这当然是对的。但我不会是其中之一。夸梅说，首先，认为盖尔不能写基米拉的故事，就是认为基米拉是由她的亚裔身份定义的，而不是由一系列不同的身份定义的，而她的种族只是其中之一。这把基米拉的经历当作某种通用的东西，好像基米拉是
a generic Asian American. Where Camilla is in fact a very particular person with a particular history and a particular set of problems. Can a white woman write authentically about Camilla's life? The test of that Kwame argues is whether Gail's original manuscript evocatively captured what it was like to be an Asian-American girl coming of age in the deep south. Conjuring Lindy so that readers can walk in her shoes, feel what she feels, dream what she dreams. This is why we have novels in the first place. Think of books like Madame Bovery, written by a man, Gustave LaBère,
一个通用的亚裔美国人。而基米拉实际上是一个有着特定历史和特定问题组合的非常具体的人。白人女性能真实地写出基米拉的生活吗？夸梅认为，检验标准在于盖尔的原始手稿是否生动地捕捉到了一个亚裔美国女孩在南方腹地成长的感受。唤起林迪的形象，让读者能设身处地，感受她的感受，梦想她的梦想。这就是我们拥有小说的原因。想想像《包法利夫人》这样的书，由男人古斯塔夫·福楼拜所写，
or to kill a mockingbird, a book with several characters of a different race and gender than the female author, Harper Lee. Kwame says that Gail, in writing about Lindy, was doing exactly what a writer should be doing. This is a woman who was trying to make sense of something and to say that she doesn't have the right to do that, I think, is to miss out on some of the great possibilities
或者《杀死一只知更鸟》，一本包含多个与女性作者哈珀·李不同种族和性别角色的书。夸梅说，盖尔在写林迪时，做的正是作家应该做的事。这是一个试图理解某些事情的女性，我认为，说她没有权利这样做，就是错失了一些伟大的可能性
of human experience. And it's to miss out on the cosmopolitan impulse, as I say, to try and make sense of things across boundaries of identity. In other words, don't we want writers to inhabit worldviews that are not their own? When we tell authors to walk only in their own shoes, are we implicitly suggesting that acts of deep empathy with other viewpoints are wrong? I play a little of what Gail said to me to Kwame.
人类经验的可能性。这也是错失了世界主义的冲动，正如我所说，试图跨越身份的界限去理解事物。换句话说，我们难道不希望作家去体验不属于他们自己的世界观吗？当我们告诉作者只能穿自己的鞋子时，我们是否在暗示对他人的观点进行深度共情是错误的？我给夸梅播放了一点盖尔对我所说的话。
I can remember a writer saying to me that she didn't think there was any way, no matter how much research I did, or how sensitive I was, or how careful I was to create something that was true, that I could possibly represent what it was like to grow up as an African American. This line of argument leads to the idea that only we only know ourselves, that there's nothing to be known outside us. It's just a way of closing yourself off from everything. And if I said to this African American writer, okay, so you can only write about black women of your class, that's your job. And then if she said, okay, I'll do that,
我记得一位作家对我说，她认为无论我做多少研究，无论我多么敏感，无论我多么小心地去创造真实的东西，我都不可能表现出作为一个非裔美国人长大的感受。这种论点导致了一种观念，即我们只了解自己，除此之外别无他物。这只是一种将自己与一切隔绝的方式。如果我对这位非裔美国作家说，好吧，那你只能写你那个阶层的黑人女性，那是你的工作。然后如果她说，好吧，我会那样做，
I would say, well, and now let's go through the other things, let's go through your sexual orientation. Are you cis or trans? Are you gay or straight? What religion are you? What church did you go up in? Well, Baptists isn't good enough because this person you're writing about as a Methodist.
我会说，好吧，现在让我们看看其他方面，让我们看看你的性取向。你是顺性别还是跨性别？你是同性恋还是异性恋？你信什么宗教？你在哪个教堂长大？好吧，浸信会还不够好，因为你写的这个人是卫理公会教徒。
You have to slip back, you have to insist that they're all Baptists. This is craziness. Kwame argues that at the heart of the debate over authenticity is an error, a philosophical error. Many of us have come to think of our experiences in the same way we think about our cars and homes and phones. Experience is not a kind of property. It's not the sort of thing that you can own. And so there's nothing essentially black for black people to own. Any more than there's something
你必须退回去，你必须坚持他们都是浸信会教徒。这太疯狂了。夸梅认为，关于真实性的辩论核心是一个错误，一个哲学错误。我们许多人开始以看待汽车、房屋和手机的方式来看待我们的经历。经历不是一种财产。它不是你可以拥有的东西。因此，黑人并没有什么本质上属于黑人的东西。就像没有什么
essentially white for white people to own or essentially Indian for Indians to own. And in that sense, I think there's a sort of philosophical mistake that underlies all this, which is to think of the things that we write about when we write about human life as belonging to people as opposed to being part of what we can share. I asked Gail to weigh in on this, the idea that the debate of a whose story it is to tell has morphed into a debate over ownership. What he's saying is stripped from any cultural context, right? So we live in a cultural moment, a specific cultural moment, and we live in a place and
本质上属于白人的东西，或者本质上属于印度人的东西。从这个意义上说，我认为这一切背后存在一种哲学错误，即认为我们书写人类生活时所写的东西是属于个人的，而不是我们可以分享的一部分。我请盖尔对此发表看法，即关于“谁的故事该由谁来讲”的辩论已经演变成关于所有权的辩论。他说的是脱离了任何文化背景，对吧？所以我们生活在一个文化时刻，一个特定的文化时刻，我们生活在一个
a time where what is published has been completely controlled by white people. And so yeah, you can totally make the argument he's making and it's a beautiful argument. And 20 or 30 years down the road, I would embrace it 100%. But right here, right now at this moment, it's not the only argument to make. Over time, Gail told me, Lutra Churmae get to a place where people of all identities feel that they have a seat at the table. But she said,
一个出版物完全由白人控制的时代。所以是的，你完全可以提出他所提出的论点，这是一个美丽的论点。再过20或30年，我会100%拥护它。但就在此时此地，这并不是唯一可以提出的论点。盖尔告诉我，随着时间的推移，文学会达到一个让所有身份的人都觉得自己在桌上有一席之地的地步。但她说，
we aren't there yet, and it's silly to pretend that we are. The true history of Lindy B. Hawkins is a story of our times. It's about undercurrents of power and privilege. It's about the many ways good people try to create a fair and inclusive world. It's a story about free speech. It's a story of historical wrongs. It's also just a great story. Through the different drafts of her novel, Gail Shepard did manage to produce something that, at least for her friend, Camilla, was recognizably authentic.
我们还没有达到那个地步，假装我们已经达到了是很愚蠢的。《林迪·B·霍金斯真实历史》是我们时代的故事。它关于权力和特权的暗流。它关于好人试图创造一个公平和包容的世界的多种方式。这是一个关于言论自由的故事。这是一个关于历史错误的故事。它也是一个伟大的故事。通过小说的不同草稿，盖尔·谢泼德确实成功地创作出了一些至少对她的朋友基米拉来说是可识别的真实的东西。
In the final version of the book, Gail returned to the story of the deer that Kimela had shot dead. But instead of pulling the trigger, Lindy B. Hawkins does something else. Here's Kimela. She does not kill the deer, it's a wounded deer, and she actually nurses the deer back to health and sets it free. And when I read the novel I cried because for me that was healing. It is in its essence a healing story, a story about healing. This week's show was produced by Jenny Schmidt and Thomas Liu. It was edited by Tara Boyle, engineering help from Gile moon. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Laura Quarelle, Pat Shah and Kat Shuknecht. Voice acting of the excerpt from the true history of Lindy B. Hawkins by Ania Vedantambi. This week we're doing something we've
在书的最终版本中，盖尔回到了基米拉射杀的那只鹿的故事。但林迪·B·霍金斯没有扣动扳机，而是做了别的事。这是基米拉。她没有杀死那只鹿，那是一只受伤的鹿，她实际上把鹿护理恢复健康并放生了。当我读到这本小说时，我哭了，因为对我来说那是治愈。它本质上是一个治愈的故事，一个关于治愈的故事。本周的节目由珍妮·施密特和托马斯·刘制作。由塔拉·博伊尔编辑，吉尔·穆恩提供工程帮助。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、劳拉·夸雷尔、帕特·沙和凯特·舒克内希特。《林迪·B·霍金斯真实历史》节选的配音由安妮亚·维丹坦比完成。本周我们正在做一些我们
never done before. We're making one of our interviews in today's episode, our unsung hero. Just weeks after recording her interview with us, Gail Shepard died suddenly of complications from a brain tumor. In her obituary, her family wrote that they would remember the way Gail challenged their minds and helped them grow as humans. By sharing her thoughts and prose and literature in our interview, Gail did the same for us. We are grateful. If you liked this episode,
以前从未做过的事情。我们正在将今天这一集中的一次采访作为我们的“无名英雄”。在录制完与我们的采访仅几周后，盖尔·谢泼德因脑瘤并发症突然去世。在她的讣告中，她的家人写道，他们会记住盖尔挑战他们思想并帮助他们作为人类成长的方式。通过在我们的采访中分享她的思想、散文和文学，盖尔也为我们做了同样的事情。我们心存感激。如果你喜欢这一集，
please be sure to share it with a friend. If they don't know how to subscribe to Hidden Brain, please show them. I'm Shankar Vedantan and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请务必与朋友分享。如果他们不知道如何订阅《Hidden Brain》，请告诉他们。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦，这是NPR。目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。